[Music]
I'm Jeff Gore from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish
today we're exploring some traditional
and non-traditional treats that may
appear in your kitchen this holiday
season from latkes in New York City to
tamales in Texas let's start with the
popularity like polarizing winter drink
eggnog Vladimir dutier takes a sip
oh
true to its name
authentic eggnog starts with you guessed
it eggs so we're gonna whip that up but
as we learned during a recent visit The
Stockade Tavern in Kingston New York
there's so much more to it we're using
cognac regular heavy cream owners Paul
Maloney and his wife Jenny use the
recipe dubbed the Baltimore eggnog which
dates back to the 1800s and here in
Kingston the first capital of New York
State it's likely some of the earliest
settlers were drinking an even older
version the Colonials drank a ton of
eggnog New England was a major rum
exporter and maker pirate juice they
call it right and so it needed to be
tamed with a little bit of cream some
sugar some eggs why is there such a
love-hate relationship with eggnog for
me it's a pure love relationship and uh
but I unders I understand that it's very
bad for you it's no worse for you than
sucking on the tailpipe of a Crosstown
bus
at the dead rabbit in New York City we
met up with cocktail historian Dave
wonderich who just completed a nearly
900 page guide he let us sample his
homemade eggnog Cheers Cheers
it's pretty good it's pretty good who is
the person who said you know what would
be really great eggs and cream and booze
and I'm gonna drink that
I mean some form it goes back to
Antiquity or certainly the Middle Ages
it does it wasn't always a seasonal
drink people did drink it year round but
New Year's day was a big deal the women
of the house would stay home with a huge
bowl of punch or eggnog or both and the
men would go to all their friends houses
and have a drink by the end of the 19th
century it's really just a special
occasion thing it has a flavor that
gives you comfort yeah when you order a
martini I don't get comfort from this
well see that might be where we differ
has it now become a drink for the new
world I mean are they still drinking it
or any other place there's uh coquito in
Puerto Rico where they use uh coconut
milk
coquito means little coconut a nod to
its main ingredient the Caribbean
holiday treat has grown in popularity
over the last few years we have rum and
then we always have coconuts on a recent
visit to Puerto Rico we stopped in
Factoria bar and met bartender Roberto
bercia who makes a recipe passed down by
his grandmother the pinch of Ginger that
gives you a little bit of taste but also
a texture when you first put ginger into
your coquito where did that come from my
grandmother used to give you hot milk
with ginger honey you make memories from
the experiences and then also you remind
memories from your palate this is your
glass wow yeah okay not unlike what
Maloney hopes to achieve all the way in
Kingston how does it make you feel when
someone who's not been a fan of eggnog
says you know what I'm converted that's
it feels great it happens all the time
while asking people like that's not for
me but you can give my date some and I
go I'll go back and be like you know
what I had a sip
now we're gonna put some nutmeg I've
never actually seen a real live no
nutmeg are you kidding happy Holidays
happy holidays thank you thanks for your
help thank you
[Music]
after the break latkes anyone we dive
into the history behind the Hanukkah
tradition next on the dish
[Music]
are a staple in Jewish Cuisine
especially during the holiday season CBS
Sunday morning's Martha teichner visited
Russ and Daughters in New York City to
learn how the potato pancakes are made
after the second or two it takes to
light that candle what is the logical
thing to do next
eat latkes of course crispy fried
slightly oniony potato pancakes with
decadent that's a euphemism for
fattening topics
[Music]
why latkes the simple answer is that
they're meant to remind Jews of the
miracle of the oil associated with
Hanukkah but this story is anything but
simple
in 164 BC
a devout Jew who called himself Judah
Maccabee and his followers overthrew the
Syrian Greek king who was trying to
impose Greek customs and religion on the
people of Israel
Hanukkah means dedication
it commemorates the victory Of The
Maccabees who retook the temple Jane
Cohen is a Jewish food historian and
cookbook writer and when they
re-sanctified the temple and cleaned
everything they needed ritual oil for
the Candelabra and the only ritual oil
that was pure enough was only enough to
last for one day according to the story
but miraculously it lasted eight days
centuries after the fact Jews were told
to celebrate by eating Foods cooked in
oil
but again why latkes
enter Judith darling of the art world
Judith was according to all accounts
this beautiful Widow and she set out to
seduce halopharnes who was holding the
town of bethulia Under Siege and she had
these very salty pancakes Levy vote and
filled them with a salty cheese and
haloperness who intended to seduce or
rape her
kept eating these and he became so
thirsty that he just drank incredible
quantities of wine until he passed out
at which point this beautiful Widow
chopped off his head
how does Judith get connected with
Hanukkah
that's where the bizarre part comes in
nobody is actually sure how the two
became conflated but they did and by the
Middle Ages Jews in Italy were eating
cheese pancakes during Hanukkah
now we come to the potato potatoes were
cheap and thanks to Poverty among
Eastern European Jews potatoes became
the key ingredient in latkes Yiddish for
pancakes like just a normal day when
there's no holiday we make a thousand a
day and then during Hanukkah we'll make
5 000 a day wow
Nikki Rush fetterman is a fourth
generation owner of Russian daughters in
New York City
for 105 years her family's business has
been Jewish food the latkes are made in
small batches by hand we commune with
ancestors when you do this watch what
you do is there a technique to squishing
just squish if there's a secret to
getting latkes right it's this this is
fun I like this
straining out extra liquid press it down
the mixture is formed into patties
which are first fried on the Griffin
then deep fried in oil canola oil here
they're meant to be eaten crispy and
warm
the story of Hanukkah and the Latka is
is one of perseverance and a little bit
of magic and that's a universal story
which is how the Brooklyn Museum
justifies certain Liberties taken by
chefs
participating in its annual latke
Festival have you ever heard of
Vietnamese latkes
or how about Korean sweet potato latkes
Mecca is considered a minor holiday for
Jews but it's got this going for it we
made them we might as well you know eat
them the towel mood judaism's book of
laws decrees that during Hanukkah there
is to be no grieving and no fasting
these are really good
no problem that's really good too if the
latkes are good and plentiful yum yeah
foreign
families take part in Traditions during
the holidays whether it be bacon cookies
building gingerbread houses or eating
The Seven Fishes for Chef Hugh Atchison
it's a fabulous family meal Dana
Jacobson gotten invites
when you start working in kitchens at
age 15 you get pretty comfortable
as a celebrity chef Hugh atchison's ease
with Cutlery and Camera Crews is pretty
much on par can you mic her up so what
we're doing next is this what you're
gonna do is just kind of pull out Azure
tightening just a little bit and that'll
form the circle more it doesn't want to
cooperate I know it's not cooperating
you guys are going to be editing this
aha yeah we're building something he's
building a crown of land
something he does each December as the
centerpiece of his family's Christmas
Eve dish I wouldn't eat this much butter
every day but that's what makes food
better it's Christmas Eve so you might
as well so now this is going to go into
an oven down there a 350. do you find
when you eat something like that that
has so many memories can you feel like
you were back in time I think the most
memorable meals of your life always pull
it a heart string of familiarity of
something you've experienced before yeah
and I think holiday dinners are really
important to kind of
ground us all you can go out for
Szechuan food on Christmas night and if
that's your tradition so be it that's
great I will say it it is my that is my
Jewish Christmas Eve that's what it is
but that's the holidays the holidays is
the memories and the repetition of of
and comfort of things that bring you all
together yeah that's traditions and so
keep on doing it
Atchison still remembers the more
everyday food he ate growing up in
Ottawa Canada we had one of the first
microwaves my dad would take acorn
squash cut it in half and put a pot of
butter in Real Canadian maple syrup and
get into the microwave and it's the best
thing ever and then we have a little
poached chicken next to it and that was
dinner it's simple have you done it
basically yeah I mean I do it all the
time when you were eating a meal like
that with your dad
would you have ever envisioned this and
what you've become
I didn't plan any of this for nearly 30
years Atchison worked in kitchens in
Ottawa Montreal and San Francisco before
settling in Athens Georgia home to the
rock band REM and the University of
Georgia in 2000 he opened five in ten
the first of two Athens restaurants a
decade later he expanded to Atlanta with
Empire State South and in October
Atchison opened by George inside the
Candler Hotel downtown
ASA built this building as kind of an
homage himself a Coca-Cola magnate Asic
Handler built the 17-floor building once
the tallest in the city in 1906. it's
funny you'll go in the staircases and
you see like Rembrandts and Socrates and
he's a Candler
this beautiful beautiful real solid
marble all the way through and these
chandeliers and things like that
Atchison named his restaurant after the
building's two architects both named
George I mean this is yeah so that's the
Tiffany Windows when they're not
illuminated the building which was last
home to a bank features the original
brass elevator doors in the lobby
downstairs atchison's kitchen sits next
to the old safe the 3 000 square foot
restaurant which sits below got its
identity from the kitchens of atchison's
Youth I'd always wanted to do a French
restaurant I'm fluent in French it's
what I was trained in and so I feel a
pedigree or a background worthy of that
to claim that his latest cookbook sous
vide is a nod to the French immersion
method of cooking food in a low
temperature bath sous-vide like
atchison's previous cookbooks includes
illustrations that he prefers to call
Doodles where did that start from you
know I come from a this family of really
interesting academics but my grandmother
was an artist one of my sisters is an
artist it was never really a skill set
that I thought I had but it was a good
way of visualizing the food that we do
and sort of planning out menus and then
it became more Whimsical it's just fun
do you do it for every meal that you're
going to do every recipe or just
randomly it's more random than anything
but Atchison did doodle the menu for our
Christmas Eve dish this is literally
what you drew is now on the table yeah
pretty much so you've got a vanilla
onion tart a really simple Savory dough
and it's almost like a quiche for lack
of a better term this is pum Anna that's
her classic French dish of layered
potatoes slowly cooked in a big copper
pan which is very old school our turnips
that have got their greens and then
braised turnips within them a simple
salad with radishes and a classic French
vinaigrette that's a salsa figurate
almost tastes like an oyster a long root
vegetable and then I've got the lamb
this to you is Christmas Eve this is
Christmas Eve pretty much every year you
know when I was young I was so bad I
would like find all my Christmas
presents not wrap them and then I would
use them and now I'll wrap them back up
and stick them under a tree nobody ever
noticed I'm just realizing there's one
thing we have not tried yet oh the Pusha
Noel
yeah are you gonna go for that I oh you
have to right who sure well is is this
classic roll cake Christmas Eve and
Christmas are all multi-generational too
it's like your your aim is to make
people happy this is just so make them a
log I mean it's chocolate and sugar in
it
good so good cheers thank you for making
it thank you thank you for coming thank
you to Atlanta to the Candler and to buy
George
right
coming up we learned about a Christmas
time tradition that requires all hands
on deck we'll show you next on the dish
the Ruiz Family of Austin Texas have
been making tamales during the holidays
for nearly five decades here's CBS
Sunday morning's morocca with a first
hand look at their Felice Navidad
tradition
foreign
s are a time for wrapping presents
wrapping houses in Christmas lights and
for the ruizes of Austin Texas like so
many Mexican-American families at
Christmas time
[Applause]
wrapping tamales
without fail the family has gathered to
wrap pork or beans in the corn flour
dough known as Masa it's chili time I
just happen to be in the neighborhood I
hope there's a lot of food because I'm
moving in a tamale making party too
is known as a tomalata she seems to be
expressing more frustration well she's
got you know she's got four children
laughs
cousins Carmen Ruth Esther and Yoli grew
up loving their grandmother's tamales
but their grandmother passed away in
1971 leaving no recipe behind so the
women turned to an elderly aunt but she
hadn't written down the recipe either we
frustrated her to no end that first time
because we were like don't put that in
there we're gonna measure it first yeah
everything she did we measured and
that's how we came up with the recipe
three generations of sisters nieces
mothers and daughters traveled from all
over the country for the two-day reunion
everything it's talked about we gossip a
lot when we're together with
announcements announcement guess who's
engaged
divorced we don't really know about it
until you get here and it's oh by the
way
it might sound fun and it is but
there are rules the bylaws all written
down this is kind of like the time a lot
of talmud
all members must attend both days
reminder if you invite your guests to
sit at the table give up your chair and
you can sit behind her
there's a pecking order too seniority
determines how many tamales members can
take home
we've kind of adjusted a lot of our
rules I know they seemed kind of silly
and kind of harsh
to some of the younger but you know what
you don't learn unless you commit okay
so what is what is my task here I'm just
Sprint oh it's just like spackling
spackling in espanol
it's probably just a spackle
[Laughter]
tamales originated in mesoamerica what
is modern-day Mexico and Central America
over 7 000 years ago they were holiday
favorites back then too given his
offerings to the gods during special
occasions
[Music]
and it was a special occasion that
brought us to San Antonio's historic
Market Square at the recent Grand
tamalada tamales were in abundance what
kind of a bean are you oh your tamale
somebody said you were a bean
a tamale is not carved in stone so it's
whatever your taste buds are hey let's
try this one or let's try that one
Professor Ellen riojas Clark is an
expert on tamales she says tamales were
the first grab-and-go meal you don't
need a fork you don't need a spoon you
don't need anything except your hands
hold the tamale push it up and you eat
it and so yes this is the first portable
food that the hunters would take on
their trips the Ruiz Family made 300
dozen tamales yes those are tamales
they'll enjoy them through the year but
it's the tradition of making them
together at Christmas time that fills
the tamalata with meaning
family traditions tend to die off when
the head of the family is gone and
children live in separate towns and you
know they don't have a reason to get
together and this was sort of our reason
to get together
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Jeff glor
happy holidays we'll see you next time
for another helping of the dish
thank you